hey hey what's up sexy how are you doing
they call me smooth skin hello welcome
to a big mood bonus episode we are all
staying
here at this lovely airbnb
in clover city california no no no it's
what it's beverly
hills beverly hills bel air
california we're like where are rich
look at this look at this look at this
irrelevant we're with the tick tockers
but not the ones that throw parties
we're not with them
okay there's only four people there's
only four people here and we all work
together and quarantine together
so we're all good in the hood but we're
here because we're doing a
shoot day tomorrow here at this exact
same location
we're sleeping over so that nobody's
late to the shoot
gina darling exactly why we are sleeping
over here
no spoilers we won't tell you what's
going on in this living room but
something is going on
something is a buzz but a lot of you
we are all a bus tip is a buzz
right now we had a
one glass of wine well just one so a lot
of you ask
uh what our skin care routines are like
when we ask you to ask us questions for
big ass mood
and well we can't really tell you on
the podcast because there's a lot of
audio listeners that can't
see what we're talking about however we
thought this would be a perfect
opportunity perfect
to show you exactly what each of us uses
for skin care for our nighttime routines
because it's all different
and we can show you exactly what we do
so with that
being said tips let's go tip the bus
ladies del rail the buzz bus
the dell really buzzed
let's bring the wine into the bathroom
we're kind of matching
[Music]
[Applause]
let me close this door so those loud ass
[ __ ] out there
[Laughter]
i have my tonic here it is
from this brand called essenza and i got
this
when i went to croatia so this is a good
three years old
oh wow okay so it's last it lasts a
while
a long time the deals the deals the
deals so as you can tell by the
amount of product that i have i don't do
my skincare routine very often but when
i do
this is what i do so first i start off
with this tonic
and i put a little bit of here i'm not
wearing makeup
or or else the very first step would be
to remove makeup but i'm not wearing
what do you use to remove makeup usually
i actually just use my
um the magic towel yes the matte i call
it magic but it's not called that magic
no no makeup eraser something like that
oh okay that's something that's a really
cool towel that all you have to do is
wet it
and then immediately you just like
remove it with this towel and it's
magic wow i want to call it magic but
it's not magic dang
yeah it's awesome so that's what i
usually do to begin with
so first off we're gonna be doing some
tonic here i kind of just
rub it around everywhere make sure it's
nice and tonicky everywhere
and this this like evens out your
complexion
girl i don't even know i think that's
what it does it's like a toner it's a
toner right
listen we know what we're talking about
whatever we say is 100 legit
estheticians come come for us exactly
i i like i said i don't know for a 1 000
but i do know that usually after makeup
removal you start off with the toner
yes all i know and what i do know as
well is that this is a water-based toner
so it's safe to use
around my eyes nice as opposed to
an oil paint alcohol base okay
alcohol base i think is not very good
for around your eyes because it dries
out the skin around your eyes it's from
whatever so maybe if you're more like
teenager skin like you're getting
breakouts a lot you would want an
alcohol
but not but not around your eyes yeah
not your eyes you're right your eye skin
is really sensitive
with the toner i could see ew look at it
you're disgusting
you're so gross actually this just looks
like i'm showing your boobs
look at her toner okay we're showing off
the toner
next i move on to my suewassu
this is rejuvenating essential
rejuvenating eye cream
and i bought this along with my
silhouettsu
activating serum in south korea
it sounds so cultured i got it at the
sunui
store and i got a facial there too which
was like the best facial thing
but yeah so i grabbed some of this eye
serum first
and then is this from when you went to
korea yes so this that's like korean
skincare is like the top of the line
legit and this is like some really
really really like super
high-end korean skincare brand level so
i'm like
what so casey actually bought me this
and that for mother's day
so it was like a nice mother's wow this
bottle is like legit too it's like a
porcelain bottle
yeah so what i do is i put it on my ring
finger and i just dab a little bit
here because they say that your ring
finger is like the lightest
yes so it's the best it's the least
abrasive
right the best finger to use when you're
you're like applying things around your
eyeballs
so then this is kind of what i do and i
just dab it because i used to be really
rough with my skin care
routine and i used to just like rub it
in and be like whatever
but then now i'm like oh my gosh it's
really important
because they say like if you just dab it
too your skin absorbs it better
it must be legit because we are experts
exactly we're experts here
do you see that it matches my my outfit
so this is the city i'm an expert did
you see how much wine we drank
we are experts look at my boobs anyway
i uh dab a little bit of this and it
smells okay so the reason why this brand
is so
popular and so expensive is because it
uses ginseng
oh and their skin care and ginseng has a
lot of anti-aging properties
i move on to the serum here and i just
do a little bit of that
and then i go like this and then
i dab it everywhere and then i try to
make sure to get my neck
peel tips a huge dabber oh my goodness
and then after i put the serum i
actually like to grab
my jade oh i almost brought mine
this is a nice little jade roller that i
received
shout out to julia she gave it to me i
watched this video when they were
talking about how to use jade rollers
and they were saying to like picture
your entire skin
like all your skin cells on your face as
if they're shutters and they're all
facing down and what you're trying to do
is roll them up oh you wanna open
up this open your skin shutters that's
what i read
i saw in the video for me particularly i
feel like
my age is really starting to show in the
jowl
area that's how i feel too even though
i'm very young
i'm very young yeah so the jowl
area here i'm like okay just roll them
yeah
yeah so then i also kind of try to like
contour my cheekbones a little bit
but you know what's crazy so when i roll
over around my eyes
i kind of roll over some certain like
nerve endings or something because then
i kind of feel like a little twitch oh
and you like it
i like it
[Laughter]
and then i use a little one to just kind
of get oh get under the eyes
little bags but sometimes if i'm not
careful this little roll
yeah it pinches
oh no so i'm like okay just oh [ __ ]
you did it oh [ __ ] listen she was
showing you what not to do
everybody this is how this is how expert
we are in here
to show you what not to do do that okay
because you can't find this anywhere
else no other skincare video we'll show
you
the real real yes don't pinch your skin
or your
your little hairs here okay moving on to
the moisturizer which is a nice pretty
funny little
step dude you think your's aesthetic
thanks so this is
white gold by oro
gold oro means gold in spanish oh [ __ ]
there you go so i kind of just rub it in
a little bit
and then dab it in a little bit and then
a little bit right here
i always forget my neck you shouldn't
forget your neck everybody
especially down in your jaw area i'm so
terrified of the space because i'm like
this is where you really see your
it really is i'm 30. you look so
young though i gotta look 19 forever yes
and i'm actually
like not on top of this routine every
day on the daily i try to be but
it's hard life is hard man it's really
hard
so i try to do that but this is this is
my skincare routine here
these uh how many products four products
that's nice
that's not too bad at all quality over
quantity
mm-hmm exactly because this is some
quality stuff
look how beautiful all right get out of
here
next jess yes caldwell that's my turn
you're next
yes how do you get this beautiful skin
of yours this porcelain beauty's
beautiful skin okay i have to admit to
you guys i
have the worst skin out of all of us as
we can see what do you say
why do you say this um because i have
pale irish skin
okay i have a lot of hyperpigmentation i
like your freckles so
what's going on and i've got some fine
lines coming in you want to zoom in on
my fine lines listen we all have that so
are you even saying that
i'm just like [ __ ] i haven't had a
skincare routine
since prior to 2019 because there was a
point in time where i had
gotten diagnosed with perioral
dermatitis
which is like i don't think anyone
really knows where it comes from
but um yeah it sounds made up it causes
uh
rashes on your face oh [ __ ] any cosmetic
products will cause like rashes so i
basically was like down to like this
most basic water-based lotion that my
dermatologist gave me couldn't use
anything on my face
for the past like year so i've just now
started and
also couldn't use sunscreen so it's a
whoa really big problem for a white girl
like me
yeah i've had a lot of sun damage to my
face for the past
year as well as this summer [ __ ] i will
tell you guys
when covet happened and the doctors were
saying oh vitamin d deficiencies
is a concern for covid i was like all
right [ __ ] it i'm in the sun
every year i was outside every day for
at least an hour i've gotten
so much sun damage you're like well i'm
[ __ ] no matter what
it's like if i'm gonna die i can i can
just be ugly now it's fine
so this is my first step into like
something that's not
the most basic dermatologist like it's
basically just water in a bottle type of
lotion like this is an actual cream
this is my first week with a skincare
routine and it's
wow two products we're on the ground
floor
we're on the ground floor so this is a
kiehl's clearly corrective
dark spot solution i have no idea i
looked at some of the ingredients it's
got some vitamin c in it and some
hyaluronic acid which is good for
high like hydrating your face and the
vitamin c is good for
youth oh no that's in this one this is a
powerful strength
line reducing concentrate from kiehl's
also it says 12.5
vitamin c and hyaluronic acid so that's
what nikki was saying is
supposed to be good for all kinds of
things yes dark spot solution
honestly guys i'm gonna probably go get
a laser treatment done because i know
that this stuff really doesn't
do a lot but i was hoping it would help
if you're in your
mid twenties you can even start younger
than that yeah like
22 actually
sure i mean start as young as possible
but if you're nearing mid-20s i'd say
start now
like just yeah hyaluronic acid and
vitamin c
it's your best friend retinols even but
you have to maybe talk to dermatologists
yeah retinols i'm like okay you couldn't
you could make a little bit of 30.
but like who knows so i think my skin's
purging i'm breaking out a little bit
but i think that's just because i
haven't used any products and also i'm
using a sunscreen now which gina gave me
nice which is a japanese sunscreen the
biore uv
water essence or whatever that's
essentially right so i'm using
all these things on my face now like
just in the last week i've been like oh
[ __ ] i need to get my [ __ ] together with
my skin because i don't think i'm gonna
die from covid
so maybe i should go back and fix the
skin that i blasted in the sun all
summer
your skin's like we've never had so many
things yeah thomas
um but yeah i forgot my face wash so
nikki let me brown hers
yeah this is purely it's really gentle
it's a gentle cleansing milk yes so it's
affordably
free yeah we're all skin tight it's very
natural very gentle
and it's uh pure leaf is a really good
brand it's gonna waste water
i don't think i got enough do it get it
i would normally use i have like this
face looper but i forgot it because i
forgot my face wash
so we're just using our fingers this
time it's okay like you need to be
really careful with
uh washcloths and loofahs because the
skin
under your eyes gets so gentle so
sensitive when you're
older you don't want to be too abrasive
i see girls do stuff like really gentle
yeah like tiff
it gives me asmr because i'm so rough
that when i see girls doing like girly
[ __ ] i'm just like mesmerized by it i'm
like whoa
i get you i'm so gentle i'm on your
level
i have jessica zamas my skin guru queen
and she's like she looks so young i'm
like whatever you're doing just tell me
just tell i just want to copy paste what
does she do i'll show you
eating babies i'll do it she actually
did the vampire facial which is like
when you take your own blood
you put it on your face but or something
yeah it's like a scrape a layer of face
i don't know
listen i it's expensive i didn't do it
but she did it once she'll do any
skincare thing yeah
i mean that's probably good too but i
want to go even further and do like
those extremely invasive laser
like there's one called halo get in me
and then there's one called fraxel
probably something like that um because
it it like goes deep into your skin and
then
like all of this hyperpigmentation and
freckles and sunspots and stuff that i
have should rise to the top whoa
that's crazy it's like fifteen hundred
dollars or something or two thousand
dollars
let me know how it goes for you waiting
i honestly i
asked someone at kiehl's which way i
should apply it and they just said you
can apply it together
so i don't really know if one needs to
come before the other but i just put
this one on because it's like creamier
and then i think this is maybe heavier i
don't know don't eat her don't eat me up
in the comments so we're gonna be
gentle vitamin c serum first and it kind
of burns a little bit at first
or it's like warming and tingly so if
you try it like don't be afraid of it
because it's supposed to do that and it
says avoid the eye area so i don't
really like
get up yeah i think i have skin cancer
right here oh no
um well like a what is it not malignant
or we're not benign benign yeah so um
because i already had one here before
cut off but then there's another one
growing i don't know if you see that red
thing right yeah a little bit yeah
i have a new one popped up oh i already
have like three cut off
but mostly they're on my legs wow well
it's like
either you stay inside you might die of
cove yeah that's the vitamin d
okay yeah i'm not gonna and i was gonna
get that sexual in here
because i have so many like i just have
these freckles everywhere but i feel
like the face
neck and chest is like yeah so usually i
would wash all of this
but i took a shower earlier usually
she'd be naked
and then we're gonna put the other serum
on and i kind of go a little bit higher
with this one i know i have a little bit
of the other one on my finger still but
it's okay
with these two things honestly i don't
really feel like i need a moisturizer
but i feel like there are
acids so yeah you can always do
moisturizer i'm supposed to go ahead and
put a moisturizer it like seals it in
yeah
so take a little bit of that definitely
the eye area
i feel like everyone's just gonna like
fast forward through mine because
they're like we don't want that [ __ ]
no i feel like you get the most
compliments on yours leave us a comment
who wants this girl's skin no everybody
does gives you your crazy because
obviously everyone else has way better
skin nah it's quite clear
dude mine was good pre getting off of
birth control it was
so good and then i don't know birth
control does a lot of hormonal things
that makes your skin look good
and once you get off it it's like oh
that's your real age
yeah i don't know i don't know anyone
that would pick like broccoli i love
freckles
pale [ __ ] up hey you're beautiful you
shut up that's my [ __ ] friend
that's my friend i'm talking about i
still love myself i just don't have
shitty skin
oh i like your i think you have such
smooth skin though
well thank you jess this is mine what a
one okay if you want her skincare
routine there it is folks there
it is i know i don't know we love you
it's only been a couple weeks so don't
this is not
this is the purge this is the idea of
this is good we don't know i think hills
is a pretty good
brand though we'll see all right gina
cochina that's me
you know the most about skincare out of
all these [ __ ] we're about to say so
i'm expecting the most we're about to
get uncoaching right now welcome to my
talk show here we go skincare do you do
you have
[ __ ] to wash off your face every day
yes make the camera not i want to make
the camera
yes yes is it hard for you to experiment
out of your mouth
yes well have i got a solution for you
yay
so i've been obsessed with skincare for
like the last like five or six years
because i went to japan and i realized
that every woman over there that's like
60 years old looks like they're 19.
yes and i lost my mind and i got deep
into the skincare routine how old were
you when you found all this out
26 oh you pitched yeah i was so lucky
i wish i went there sooner i know so i
always
preach sunscreen yes and like in
everything so sunscreen every day i
literally wear sunscreen even when i'm
at home
because it's for the blue light from
your um your computer
and then also when you're your phone or
when you walk
like around the house and the windows
it's all sunny and crap so
i wear sunscreen every day i literally
feel like uncomfortable if i don't have
sunscreen
yeah like i first naked first thing i do
in the morning is wash my face and just
put on a ton of sunscreen
so the end of the day you have to wash
off all that sunscreen and all that
makeup right yes
so what i do is a double cleansing
method it's a huge thing in asia so what
you do is you cleanse with oil
first oh [ __ ] and i've never heard of
this so you cleanse with oil first i use
the shu amore skin purifier
this one the oil gets like it breaks
down all your makeup all the impurities
all the dirt and everything in your
pores
so i use that first because i need to
break or break down all of my
sunscreen and my makeup that i have you
know the sperm
and the sperm sperm all those you don't
want babies in your face
what's that it's gross right come on
she uses this every day this is my first
time traveling with this this is working
this work oh my god
[Laughter]
it knows what you like where did it land
i'm having a hard time because i have um
i have i burned myself yesterday
what happened i was cooking and some hot
oil splashed all over my finger like you
can see the bubbles oh no
oh look how gross it is you see the way
hold on let me focus it mm-hmm
[Music]
so two pumps of oil and not hot oil
not hot oil and then you just rub it all
over your face
and you get rid of like it breaks down
all the makeup and it's so funny like on
days when i'm wearing
super heavy makeup it breaks it all down
and when i'm done i just
look like a panda but then how do you
get the mascara out and all the eyeliner
out from underneath you just rub
rub like i get in there oh wow look i
just get in there i
rub but you don't want to go too crazy
but eventually you'll start noticing
that the
your clog pores and all that it actually
comes out and you can feel it
in your hand under my chin also because
i put sunscreen everywhere i also put it
on my neck so i'm gonna rub it on my
neck too
instead of being like a routine it's
becoming a therapeutic thing for me
because this is like self-care you know
this is like how you love yourself every
day you
take care of your skin because your skin
is the biggest organ on your body
and like when i'm old i want to flux out
all the young idiots and be like look my
skin looks [ __ ] crazy yeah like how
old do you think i am
all right 19. guess again next thing you
do is you add water to it so it
emulsifies
oh big words yeah big word so
you add to it and then it emotionally
turns all white
and then i kind of rinse it lightly
that's cleanse number one
the oil cleanser right yeah and the next
thing is you go in with a regular
cleanser to wash off everything else wow
stuff so i use this one the sk2 cleanser
and this is a water base
mm-hmm so this is a water-based cleanser
and then i just
super kind of try to
give it a nice massage and then like on
days that i need
super extra love
hey hey what's up sexy how are you doing
they call me smooth skin oh dang i don't
want to find out why they call me
i don't i don't it ain't just smooth
here i'm scared
that ain't the only thing that's move
around here
you're terrifying horrible it's a
silicone
cleanser you turn it on and it vibrates
and i don't necessarily even know if it
really does anything i knew the same
because it's not like that um clarisonic
bristle one where you could like feel it
slopping off your skin exactly like so
gentle which outline is actually bad for
your
that's what i heard too so that's where
i switched to this thing
and it's not it's uh this one's more
hygienic because the silicone doesn't
get
all bacteria infested exactly it's
little porous
my cleansing method is my favorite
because it just makes me feel so
good yeah okay i pat dry
i never dragged my face i never rub good
because i don't want wrinkles i don't
want to thin out my skin especially
around the eyes so i pat dry
my next step is my toner in asia
they don't call it a toner they call it
um lotion
oh yeah which is really weird because
even though it's all watery yeah exactly
because you think lotion is like this
thick thing that you see
yeah on your body but it's actually this
so it's toner which will help
everything that you use kind of absorb
into your skin better so i put in
toner for a little bit you don't even
use like a cotton or anything
because i find that cotton soaks it up
and it wastes that's true
yeah i never thought of that mm-hmm so
you just kind of pat it in
give myself a few slaps some into that
you know it's a good blood flow you know
after the vibrator yeah exactly
slide yourself a bit my face is
literally my clitoris
my clean quote of the day and then very
important make sure you guys take care
of your necks in the back of your hands
too
those necks because you can do all these
procedures on your face
to keep yourself looking young but your
neck will give it away
your neck and your hands the back of
your hands will always it will betray
you
it's like an upward massage oh that's
nice that's like a facial person's doing
it
okay toned absorb right yes
and then the next thing i like to do is
so i always go by what's thinnest
first consistency yes and then i go to
the thicker one so my next one
is an essence as you can see this is my
favorite brand
yeah i stock up on this when i go to
asia sk2
what's an essence i don't know
good for you so i basically do the same
thing
just put in their cat i have like
combination
dehydrated skin so like here i'm like
kind of oily in the morning
but here i'm like super dry so i like to
just like
layer on another moisturizer and my
favorite one is this one
it's a goku gym from hadalabo gokujen
and it's like this it's such a nice
consistency it's like it's like a little
bit oily because where do you find this
stuff
um just japanese markets huh yeah
japanese i've never seen that
so this one is like one of the
best-selling things in asia
and it's really affordable you can get
this in like drugstores and like
whatever stores and it's so good
and it's so light like if you just need
like a quick moisturizer it's not like a
cream or anything yeah you slap this on
your face and right before makeup it
absorbs it like it's just so like
it's kind of slimy but it absorbs so
well wow
i just rub it on my face gently
i actually have to wait 20 minutes i
have like a custom made skincare cream
and it comes with a
chemical called tretinoin it's almost
like a retinol uh-huh it's really good
for your skin like you should start
using retinol
early on like it's anti-aging it's good
for your wrinkles it's good for pores
and everything
and it's like it's one of those like a
little goes a long way i think mine's
like 0.025
yeah and like you put that on your face
like you use it every other day or every
two days because it's
[ __ ] strong right but like it
exfoliates my top layer it gets rid of
like small fine lines it makes my pores
smaller it evens out my skin tone it's
so good
but i can only use a little bit of time
and you have to wait 20 minutes after
washing your face
otherwise it'll just mess up your skin
pretty badly oh [ __ ] so i do all this i
wait 20 minutes and then i use
one tiny pump of this and then i mix it
with my actual like face cream
and mix it all together oh yeah where'd
you learn to do that
my dermatologist oh wow i never would
have thought to do that
yeah because like it's just such a
little amount and you want to spread it
better
right and you don't like sometimes you
don't necessarily want the whole
like just raw you don't want to yeah you
want a raw dog you know
i feel like that's been my biggest
problem with retinols it's just so
strong
yeah so you mix it with a nice face
cream or whatever and then i put that
over my face
and then my last step is i put um
aquaphor on my lips so it's not
drying oh and that's my whole entire
skincare nice
yeah so in 20 minutes you're gonna do
that mixture in 20 minutes i'm gonna mix
that together i'm going to put on my
face and then
i go to bed and then the next day you
wash it off but the thing with retinol
is if you're going to use retinol like
that because it peels off so much
yeah you must must absolutely use
sunscreen
huh otherwise it will your face will
absolutely get messed up right so you
use a bunch of sunscreen with that too
and you want to use retinol
at night time at night time yeah only
yeah so you just sleep on it
and then it's like you start having this
thing called like glass skin
oh yeah your skin looks like it's really
shiny whatever whatever
but it some people like it with oily but
it's not it's just well hydrated
mm-hmm so that's why when i do like
filming and stuff i have to put
powder on because it's not that i'm oily
it's just like i'm shiny now because
it's like this glass
skin that's actually been a trend with
makeup lately mm-hmm
to try to get that look to try to fake
that look yeah
and then that's all and that's it that's
how you look like a queen
queena oh yes
[Laughter]
day one of following nicking to the
bathroom
this is my nighttime routine it's
normally very private
we already she already did all the
chanting and stuff so we're we're good
it's fine now
so that's pretty good now the ritual has
been done so
this is my nighttime nighttime routine
currently but as you can tell by my
speech i've had a few glasses of wine
let me tell you something about alcohol
it does not make your skin good it
messes with your your uh epidermis and
your
it just you know messes with your
hormones all kinds of stuff but big work
you know 2020 we're learning that uh
we just we sometimes we don't care we
just google alcohol
okay so before 2018
i was on like birth control pills and my
skin was
so clear and it was so good and i was
like it's cause my skincare routine
it was because of the hormones so once i
got off i was like
wait why are all these wrinkles
happening and these breakouts i don't
know
but this is the best we got so if you
wanted to know
here is my skincare routine and most of
this was taken from just the zama
this is what i would start with and i
like this because
it's a gentle cleanser oh gosh from pure
elise
oh you can clap you can't oh sorry you
can't touch this oh wait wait
i'm getting there there you go hell yeah
it's a gentle cleansing milk
it cleanses removes makeup tones ensues
and
uh soap and sulfate free what i like
about this
is that it gets off all your makeup like
so if i was wearing
tons of makeup right now it gets off
mascara
it gets off foundation anything you
would want this to get off it gets off
and then i also put it
on my exfoliator device that gina had
earlier
i didn't bring my i forgot but usually i
would go back in with it and it's so
gentle that it doesn't really mess your
skin up too much let's get that going
some warm water going out of our
elementary school drinking fountains
god remember those kids that used to put
their mouth over the whole fountain
yes and you always wanted that
oh that kid's definitely in prison now i
hope karma got to him yeah
he's definitely in prison now for sure
for sure
my face moist get a nice moist everyone
loves that word
mm-hmm and now it just
it's gentle you know like be very gentle
with your skin i feel like when you're
younger you're just like
get it off blackheads out or whatever
but then when you're older like
i need to be gentle because i'm forming
wrinkles when i'm
rough watching gina made me want to like
do it like uh
it's not really how i do it and normally
when i have mascara on i would start
here on my eyes and just really get in
there and get all that mascara off
mascara is the bane of my existence at
night
but it's the light of my life during the
day that's why i told you man oil
cleansers
yeah i've never used life-changing but i
do want to try now mm-hmm
i don't use washcloths or anything
because i don't want to be too abrasive
good yeah i do an exfoliator
and this one is an alpha hydroxy beta
hydroxy exfoliator
i switch this off between doing this and
doing the vibrator
guy so tonight because i did um vibrator
guy last night
yes i did we're doing the alpha hydroxy
one tonight and this uh my esthetician
added to my routine just this year
because she said that oh thank you she
added to my routine just this year
because she said that
uh you need to do a physical and a
chemical exfoliator
when you get older i hate how i hate
using the term older
we're like only 20 years old but i think
they just jump in the gun yeah like when
once you're past your teeth
yeah yeah yeah we don't have to worry
about it as much because we're still
like super
very so young but this particular one
feels tingly you know i feel like i
don't know i like to feel when it when
things are being cleansed out it's very
satisfying
and it has such small exfoliating
things like very very very tiny because
you don't want the micro beads
those little plastic microwaves that
were popular in the 90s those are a huge
no-no they like pollute the environment
they're like
bad for your skin it's a no-no and this
just like unclogs all of those you know
those pimples you get that are like
little and they don't form a white head
or a black head and you like can't pop
them it's annoying they just kind of are
raised bumps
this like helps to cleanse those guys
out i think it's so unfair how men
literally wash their face with like
vegetable oil and they have the greatest
skin in the world
they don't deserve it although i will
say that steve did
several tours of accutane so this was
that was good
yeah so i feel for him what i really
enjoyed was seeing everybody's
everybody's toner
everybody's got that toner i i use this
pixi glow tonic
i heard really good things about it and
i was planning on buying it
and then i won it in a raffle not a
charity so i was like it's meant to be
and i gotta say yeah it does i feel like
it does do a good job at like
evening skin tone and complexion usually
i use a cotton pad but i forgot mine and
then i just saw gina doing this on her
face so i'm like oh you could do that
i like that brand because it's like so
affordable it's at target oh yeah
i've seen it at target they'll always up
motion
it's like you're like please please come
back
stop going to the floor come back we
should sleep with our heads upside down
from now on so gravity fills it up
slightly tilted back some pure
hyaluronic acid serum and what you can't
put that on yet what you have to wait 20
minutes also
why because really yeah [ __ ] why tell me
it will dry it out from what i know with
hyaluronic acid you either have to have
a liquid like you have to spritz it with
water first already
because parallelic acid pulls liquid and
if it's not pulling like moisture from
anywhere it's pulling from your face
oh my god so you have to put it you have
to like spritz your face with water or
something first and then you put on
hyaluronic acid oh my god i didn't know
that that's
so much sense i could be wrong but
that's what i learned so far
like that's what i learned from it but
why did you wait 20 minutes wait am i
mixing with 20 minutes with
okay no no sorry not the 20 minutes but
whenever you use higher leuronic just
make sure that you have some sort of
like
water like moisture like a misting or
rose mist or something on it yeah
so just like just a little bit because
it needs to work with some sort of
moisture
like oh there you go that's right it's
in in the eyes
oh and it's
a mist now find a fine mist a fine mist
on your face
can i tell you i was lying earlier i
don't normally use this
in the night time i normally use it in
the daytime only
so i normally go from like cleansing dry
to hyaluronic acid but
in the morning i do use this first with
no moisture or anything and then go to
hyaluronic acid
i'm trying to do it now yeah okay
hopefully that i'm sorry hopefully that
was enough for you baby
we do three drops and i just
i just like pat it into it so that the
skin cells
wake up and i'm like hey i'm putting
youth back into you
please let my kids have a young mother
please let people think i'm a teen
pregnancy
another serum that i love is this
vitamin c serum
although i've been told to only do
vitamin c if it's pure vitamin c to do
it only in the daytime
i don't know i don't know but it was not
by a doctor it was just by a person
from what i know people use it in the
evening also all right [ __ ] it we're
doing it
whatever we're gonna see what we can get
it's a still a good light orange color
good
yeah and what i heard was also
that you want to put these serums on
first because
they have smaller molecules so they go
into your skin
easier and then but if you put the
moisturizer on first
then that blocks them from being able to
go penetrate your
epidermis so you would like to put those
serums in
first okay then i got pretty yeah
of eye cream like i heard good things
about this brand
i just really liked the packaging on it
and it just seemed very clean and
very creamy and i was like oh this kind
of looks like something special that
gina might put on her face so
i'm gonna use it i just put a little bit
of it on my finger
and then just kind of lightly
dab it around this area with my ring
finger because
that's like the one that has the least
amount of
pressure moisture is your best friend i
learned i don't know if it's still like
this for teens because they're a lot
more
hip to knowledge than i was when i was a
teen because we used to get our
information from like cosmo magazine
but it was always like trying to zap all
the moisture because like
oily stuff makes your skin break out
but now i've realized that like no like
a lot of times you break out because
your skin's too dry
you gotta put oil on there so i
sometimes put
marcus oil on but i don't have it today
and then
i do this moisturizer also from pixie
it's a rose
ceramide cream yay i like love the knot
of approval from gina whenever i
like like this is this one am i doing
good
that's right and then she she's like got
sad mad at the like kylo rock after i
was like oh no no
no i messed up so then i do like you
know
get an even on my face like this you
want
i just like to get as hydrated as
possible
i know you don't like it but i like that
mark on your face on your cheeks thank
you
your little comma oh yeah thank you
there's periods and things but comments
keep going even when things get rough
and you don't stop you just keep going
that's a run-on sentence but yeah
it needed a comma there's a comma in
there
so you call it his kiss target
so like that was in my mind when i went
to the dermatologist and i was like so
what do i do with this can you laser it
off or whatever and they're like well we
can but then
if you're in the sun for like two hours
it'll come back oh so i was like oh
is it worth going through all that to
get rid of my kiss target
yeah oh sorry this is a pumpkin sleeping
pack
that julia had got us miniature versions
of for christmas
and then gina told me it was like the
best thing ever to sleep with
and then i did it and i woke up with
such smooth skin i went to bed i had
bumps all over my face from like
little pimples that weren't fully there
yet and i went
i woke up i did this on a vlog and you
can see it and like i showed the before
and after like i went to bed with it on
and then i showed them in the morning
and they were gone like the bumps were
gone
so i'm a huge believer now and you just
like you get really generous with this
you can go like you
put like that much on the last step my
pillow might hate me
my face is just so moist when i go to
bed
the sleeping packs pretty much the last
step of your whole entire routine it
seals everything and he's a big boy he's
a thick boy
that really helps like going from
thinnest to thickest like no keeping
that in mind
i never thought about that yeah so
you're like and your face just looks
pretty wet
but you know it's not it's it's the
glass skin
yeah it's the glass skin transitioning
exactly imagine waking up just glowing
like this
amazing i did i just woke up yeah you
just woke up totally it's like seven in
the morning right now yeah
it's crazy morning good morning coffee
welcome to the vlog yeah and that's our
skincare routines
uh that was everybody's skincare routine
we're done so let us know
in the comments if you got some useful
information from this if this helped you
if you have tips
that you would like to share we would
love to hear them because i mean besides
gina i feel like the rest of us are kind
of new we're just kind of trying to do
things right
and we never know we're doing it so let
us know in the comments what you think
also please like the video subscribe all
that noise and
we're going to have some really fun
stuff coming up that's why we're here
we already compared boobs we did we took
them all out
we just won boo beach just one nobody
gets both
yay we did it
you